Hello everyone. I'm Stefan from Frewings, and today I'm going to talk a bit about the topic of legislation and air law.
It can be a bit of a scary topic, or one that during the SHV exam-prep phase we tend to push back a little bit in time.
Maybe also because in the book it comes across as quite dry.
Today's goal is on one hand to take away some of that hesitation, and also to show the practical side of the whole legal part.
At first glance it might not seem as practice-relevant and exciting as, say, tricks or flight practice.
We don't have to know every single Swiss airspace by heart.
If we just know that when I go to a flying site, I have to check the airspace situation that day in general.
Then we can launch into the flight with a good feeling.
Good, so now we'll get going with the next few slides.
First, again, the definition of hang gliders.
We also have a sailplane or an aeroplane.
Aerodynamically speaking, but still capable of forward flight.
And with our paragliders, we also fall into this category.
Then we can move on to the legal foundations.
The federal government sets the legal provisions for Swiss aviation.
Oversight of all of aviation lies with BAZL (FOCA).
The federal government is also responsible for civil aviation.
And BAZL in turn delegates the execution of all hang-glider regulations to the SHV.
The Swiss Hang Gliding Association.
The SHV mainly handles training and exams.
Together with the insurance side, for the third-party liability insurance for our sport.
They take care of competitions, of youth promotion, of various flying sites,
of wildlife protection, of airspaces.
And all of that is coordinated.
And it gives us a nice framework that allows us to practise our hobby here in Switzerland.
The legal provisions are written down in the VLK.
That's the Ordinance on Aircraft of Special Categories.
The VLK mainly says how and where and who can fly with such a paraglider.
We can also just google it, so we don't have to learn every paragraph by heart.
It's just important to know what the VLK is and why it exists.
It's not all that bad if it's not memorised.
It's three, four, maybe five pages, which we can work through.
And not everything in it has to be learned by heart.
Then we can move on to further fundamentals about hang gliders.
So paragliders, hang gliders, or kites.
We're not aircraft in the traditional sense.
Aircraft.
(unclear)
And the aircraft.
Our advantage that we are hang gliders,
is that we have the partnership with the association.
Through that, with plenty of members, we get good insurance.
Through the employer or through health insurance,
if you hit someone on the ground, or even an object on the ground.
If after landing you damage a parked car, for example,
then your private liability won't cover that, and that's where it becomes really important
that you actually have a hang-glider liability insurance in place.
Landing and launching on public roads and also on ski runs is forbidden.
It's important that we stick to that.
And what makes things easier: there's no minimum altitude required for hang-glider flights.
So as a pilot, in that sense, you don't have to log a minimum amount of flying,
though it makes sense of course to stay current and to build routine in this sport,
or, if you've had a longer break, to do a refresher course.
But legally, no minimum number of flights is required.
Swiss airspace is fairly tightly nested.
We're very densely populated, and we also have a lot of air traffic.
But aside from everything that happens in the air, it's also very important
that we follow certain rules on the ground too.
And here I'm thinking mainly of all the federal protected areas,
the cantonal wildlife sanctuaries, and there are also private protected areas,
as well as local agreements with game wardens and hunters.
And a big part of that you can find on this page, map.geo.admin.ch,
which the SHV also covers on their homepage under flying sites and wildlife protection.
If you go there, you can also check where you can paraglide and where there are wildlife concerns.
Downloading the document as a PDF is very informative,
showing that the forests are where the wildlife is under pressure, and on the ground,
we should try to keep distance, especially at certain seasons.
I'd warmly recommend taking a look at that.
We'll focus mainly on the airspace restrictions, of course.
And with that we move on to right of way.
In aviation it's always right-hand right of way,
so it's quite similar to road traffic:
the pilot coming from the right has right of way.
We have to react quickly, even though a paraglider is one of the aircraft
that flies very slowly.
We still need to live by the motto: see and be seen,
so really look out properly.
Try to anticipate
what the others in the air might do next,
what their intentions might be, who might fly through where.
And start giving way early,
before things even get tight.
Or before you're even in the position of deciding
who actually has right of way.
The real goal is to react beforehand,
so that you avoid such a situation entirely.
When things get a bit tight.
The distance isn't actually defined either.
It's a bit short, or just give way a little,
and on a wide open landing field,
if it gets tight at all, regarding the topic
of wingtip vortices, and what happens when you fly close to each other,
in a thermal column, this is also a recurring situation
you experience on a flying day,
when we're flying inside a thermal column.
And then you need to be aware,
of who turns which way.
What's really interesting is that it's not
the lower or the upper pilot
who must determine which way it goes,
but rather, whoever was first into the thermal
sets the direction of turn.
So even a higher pilot,
or someone else,
if the lower one is turning the other way,
because it can happen
that the lower pilot flies a bit better,
has a better wing,
or simply turns more smoothly in the thermal.
And catches up,
and if you end up at the same altitude
turning in opposite directions,
then when you approach each other,
(unclear)
you have a high relative speed difference,
which again can become
dangerous.
So it's always very important
to turn in the same direction.
And something else interesting,
I'd also point out: with birds too, turn in the same direction,
in the same direction as them.
It might feel fun,
but birds too,
in our region right now,
where paragliding is so widespread,
are used to us.
And they turn peacefully,
in most cases,
right alongside us.
But if we start
turning the opposite way,
we scare them off,
in the worst case,
we effectively drive them away,
out of their home territory,
which clearly wouldn't be good.
So please don't.
It might feel fun,
but let's make sure
we turn in the same direction as the birds.
And usually we climb much better that way anyway,
or if we get above them,
we'll climb pretty quickly.
Then we can move on to right of way at the ridge.
Again here,
we start with a photo
to begin with,
to get the picture right,
not just at 90 degrees on the photo
but also at the fronts,
always picking the right angle.
At the ridge, the rule is
that of the two,
the one with the ridge on the right,
to the right,
has no option to give way, or barely, like a dream.
Again here it's lovely if the paraglider pilot flies considerately
and starts giving way early, like I do, instead of only realising at the last moment.
Yes.
A few metres, where the ridge will definitely be better afterwards along the slope.
Again, we look at it: the time, the chance, the topic,
turn away from the ridge a bit, so the other wing knows,
yes, they've seen me, and then there's room to fly past.
And much more: I find that flying right up against the ridge isn't necessarily better
than staying a little further out.
Exactly, that way you avoid the bumper situation.
Then there's the definition of overtaking.
This is very theoretical and very focused on the legal part,
but it's described in the book.
And I've often had flight students ask me about it,
because they were a bit confused by the explanation or the diagram.
It's really mainly about
distinguishing what counts as overtaking
and what counts as simply crossing or approaching from the right.
And it's described with an angle of 70 degrees,
so two times 70 degrees, giving 140 degrees,
anything coming from behind within that range counts as overtaking.
But if you're in front of that line, in front of the 70-degree line,
then, like the blue one,
actually has right of way over the green one,
because they're coming from the right.
But the red one, the lower one, has no right of way
because they're the one overtaking, and the one who overtakes
never has right of way.
So always, the one being overtaken,
has the right of way, because they can't easily see
what's happening behind them.
Right, and again in practice this rarely comes up,
because ideally you try, well in advance of the situation,
to get out of the way.
And you definitely don't try
to force a right-of-way claim.
Then more right-of-way rules:
an aircraft on fire, or to put it another way,
simply an aircraft
that's in an emergency,
has the highest right of way,
because they can no longer manoeuvre well.
And the aircraft, like a helicopter or a powered aircraft,
for example, that have full manoeuvring capability,
they have no right of way.
So they have to give way.
And that's basically a stick figure on the slide.
Second would be balloons.
Logically they can't really give way either.
Next, this is interesting.
We come together with paragliders and sailplanes.
We're in the same category,
even though a sailplane of course flies much faster
than a paraglider.
But in terms of right-of-way rules, we're in the same category.
After that come zeppelins,
where we have right of way over the zeppelin.
After that come tow-planes,
because they're relatively well able to manoeuvre,
and finally aeroplanes and helicopters.
Okay, now we can move on to the main part
of the whole presentation.
And that's the glider chart.
And why do we even need a glider chart?
Or what is a glider chart?
What's it good for?
Sailplanes and hang gliders.
On the glider chart you find airspace classes,
hazards, restricted areas.
And glider sectors for us.
The glider sectors are for sailplanes and gliders.
That way sailplanes and military aviation stay separated.
Normally that's very important.
As mentioned, in Switzerland the airspace is fairly tightly nested.
And that's why it's so important that we stick to the airspaces
and only fly where we're permitted, and keep a good lookout.
Because it has already happened
that pilots have climbed so high in thermals
that they end up in the approach corridors near airports.
That has happened several times.
This is just one example.
And it's of course, first and foremost, extremely dangerous.
For us we now have the glider chart with sectors.
We have to keep ourselves to those sectors.
(unclear)
They enter the glider sector through these gates.
We have the glider sector through these gates.
Right, that's good.
We have it in a line.
We have it from the gates.
The glider sector through the gates.
(unclear)
(unclear) quite a few flying sites are affected.
So it's really important to stay in the legal zone.
Glider charts you can buy.
And then there's the map.geo.admin.ch link, which you can open.
There you've got the electronic digital charts,
you can also pull in the legend, open it as a PDF,
where all the texts and symbols are described.
Personally, I also find it useful
to have a physical chart in your hands.
It just gives you a bit of an overview.
You can orient yourself a bit better.
You shouldn't be too intimidated by it,
because at first glance it does look quite intimidating or complex.
But it's good that you mostly fly in one specific area.
And when you zoom in a bit,
it's not as bad as it looks if you just stare at the whole of Switzerland.
A new edition comes out every March,
which you can then buy.
Honestly speaking, I don't buy the newest one every year.
I have one from the last two or three years,
just to get the overview.
And before I go flying,
I always check online anyway,
because then I have the most up-to-date version.
Now we can move on to a few abbreviations,
which will keep coming up throughout the presentation,
also in connection with the glider chart.
The abbreviation GLDC stands for glider chart,
which we've just briefly covered and which we'll go through more carefully.
AIP is the Aeronautical Information Publication.
There we have generally valid information for all users of Swiss airspace.
Then we have the NOTAM.
This is a daily-published information source for aviators,
where airspace restrictions and also hazards and obstacles on the ground are noted.
And DABS — Daily Airspace Bulletin Switzerland —
that's actually, alongside that, the main instrument
I check before I go flying.
Because in DABS they also publish daily
which airspaces are currently active and where you can't fly.
We'll come back to that later in a practical example.
Then we have lots of abbreviations here,
and again I'd recommend
taking a photo or screenshot.
That way you can review the abbreviations anytime.
Very important, when it comes to altitudes,
is to always check whether it's above ground or above sea level.
That's really important so no mistake creeps in.
Then VFR — VFR stands for Visual Flight Rules, so sight-flight rules.
And that's actually the regime
we move in with our paraglider.
IFR, so Instrument Flight Rules,
exists only for aircraft
that are properly equipped for instrument flight.
And only pilots who hold the necessary licence for that.
And we with the paraglider, no matter how much GPS and how many instruments we strap on,
do not fly under instrument flight rules and we do not fly into clouds.
We'll come back to that later as well.
But the really important thing to remember: with the paraglider, only VFR applies to us.
Then later we'll move on to Flight Levels
and what they all include.
The three labels CTR, TMA and AWY,
these are mostly, or always, in the vicinity of airports.
So CTR always extends from the ground up to a certain altitude.
The TMAs are essentially the approach corridors for takeoff and landing.
And the airways are then the longer airspaces
where the major route segments and connections between airports come together.
We'll come back to that in more detail later too.
And these airspaces always have a name.
And it mostly starts, or in Switzerland it always starts, with LS.
That means L stands for Lower Europe and S stands for Switzerland.
And for example LSZR would be Altenrhein.
Then comes the suffix, that's two letters about the airport.
Where the suffix LSZH stands for Zurich.
And there are also restricted areas and so on.
We'll come back to those later too.
Worldwide there are seven different airspace classes.
They're set by ICAO, the International Civil Aviation Organization.
In Switzerland, we only use four of them.
Those are G and E.
These are free, meaning we can fly through them.
And C and D are only allowed to be flown through with clearance and radio contact.
That means if somewhere,
it may happen at some point, if you're on a long cross-country flight,
that you end up right next to an approach corridor, for example.
And then we have the option to call them on the radio
and, under constant radio contact,
we may be able to cross the approach corridor.
But that's not guaranteed of course.
So it's only with clearance and with constant radio contact.
Only with E and G can you always fly through.